the rainforest this is for me
magical
but we need to understand that that
magic diversity is so fragile
the diversity of species is an indicator
of the
shade of the forest
there are many elusive and braided
species that is very difficult to sing
i work here 10 years and only one
time i see a puma
so far
maybe only the tail
with the improvement in technology we
can increase the amount of information
that we can gather about
tropical forests and terrestrial
batteries
we use digital camera traps that collect
consistent data that can be comparable
across the world
but how can we process that big data
that is where hewlett-packard enterprise
plays a very important role
hewlett-packard enterprise allow us to
summarize that huge information
for policy makers and park managers and
conservationists across the world
i feel so happy when i see a puma
therapy
because it's a good indicator of the
health of the rainforest
as a mother there is a need to protect
the planet hey amira
faces
despite the pressure from human
the nature has a extraordinary ability
to recover
we just need to give it a chance
you